et nous qui pensions que le bon vieux
Canal+ à un canal le bon vieux canal
avait disparu mais non bienvenue sur la
chaîne d'infos du bon vieux canal le
canal de gauche la santé tout de suite
avec le docteur Brigitte Millot bonjour
Docteur Millot bonjour on va parler
aujourd'hui de la cocaïne
partout c'est très facile de s'en
procurer je vais vous téléphoner vous
vous pouvez vous faire livrer la cocaïne
mais si c'est trop tard bon c'est pas
grave on est sur Canal
dans la cocaïne on a la dopamine la
dopamine c'est plutôt le transmetteur du
plaisir du désir de l'euphorie alors
quand on voit ça on peut dire finalement
c'est sympa votre truc parce que ça
donne envie tout ça pas du tout et c'est
là qu'elle aurait dû s'arrêter mais elle
a continué pas du tout c'est sympa une
petite dose mais nous retiendrons donc
cette déclaration du médecin de cnews la
cocaïne c'est sympa
alors derrière sur le site de TF1 je
vous ai dit regardez ce qu'ils ont mis
ça c'est c'est compliqué sur cnews un
médecin vante les mérites de la cocaïne
et Brigitte est avec nous merci Michel
Brigitte avec nous médecin et
chroniqueuse on va revoir la vraie
chronique d'accord avant 6 minutes non
pas tout entière t'inquiète pas mais on
va voir voilà la séquence sur cnews et
regardez et c'est vrai que je sais que
ça a été un déferlement aujourd'hui
autour de toi il y a plein de gens qui
m'ont écrit d'ailleurs là-dessus parce
que c'est vrai que quand on reprend que
l'extrait voilà et quand on voit la la
voilà la malhonnêteté voilà du montage
et de ce qui a écrit sur le site de TF1
c'est vrai que ça peut être compliqué
pour toi regardez je vais vous montrer
les principaux transmetteurs qui sont
impliqués dans la cocaïne on a la
dopamine dont on vient de parler la
dopamine c'est plutôt le transmetteur
normalement du plaisir du désir de
l'euphorie après on a la sérotonine qui
va un peu temporiser tout ça mais qui
est aussi l'hormone de la confiance en
soi par le transmetteur de la confiance
en soi du bien-être et enfin la
noradrénaline elle s'est plutôt
l'énergie l'éveil alors quand on voit ça
on peut dire finalement c'est sympa
votre truc sauf que ça donne envie tout
ça pas du tout c'est sympa à petite dose
mais quand il y en a plein en permanence
et bien tout ça ça va se transformer sur
des effets négatifs sur tout notre
système
alors Brigitte on a raté le début le
début au début en fait ce que j'explique
c'est que les neurotransmetteurs que
nous avons tous en a tous de la dopamine
elle noradrénaline en fait ils sont
libérés dans l'espace et quand on prend
de la cocaïne ça empêche la réabsorption
de ces neurotransmetteurs et donc en
fait il y en a plein plein dans l'espace
et du coup ça provoque tous les effets
secondaires et je passe 6 minutes à
expliquer les dangers de la cocaïne ou
une heure après la prise de cocaïne le
risque d'infarctus est multiplié par 24
risque d'accident vasculaire cérébral
est multiplié par 10 j'explique tout ça
pendant les six minutes à aucun aucun
aucun moment je ne parle de la cocaïne
je parle des neurotransmetteurs et je
dis à petite dose ça va les
neurotransmetteurs mais à forte dos ça
ne va pas et donc elle est manipuler en
mettant un panneau comme je ne l'ai pas
dit il a pas pu mettre bout à bout la
cocaïne la petite dose ça va comment on
peut faire des choses comme ça je ne
comprends pas quel est l'objectif si je
suis là c'est pour rétablir la vérité si
vous étiez sur LCI ça se serait parfait
c'est plus le plus le problème c'est
qu'à vouloir justement absolument cette
haine de la chaîne de cnews les pouces à
faire des fautes professionnelles
comment on peut faire un montage et
d'une malhonnêteté à ce point-là comment
en plus on devrait tous être derrière le
enfin je sais pas tous être ensemble
unique contre la contre la dopamine
contre la cocaïne vous voyez j'en arrive
à perdre on devrait tous être là
ensemble comment il peut arriver à dire
en plus ça peut être dangereux il y a
des jeunes qui peuvent entendre ça ils
se dire mais alors si le médecin de du
Cap petite dose c'est bon je vais en
prendre des petites doses c'est-à-dire
qu'on peut être responsable à cause de
manipulation comme ça on peut être
responsable de gens qui vont prendre des
petites doses et à qui il peut arriver
quelque chose avec la cocaïne même une
dose parfois ça peut suffire va
provoquer des arrêts cardiaques je
trouve ça insensé dangereux médiocre
minable malhonnête surtout regardez
Pascal Praud très énervé regarde hier
soir l'émission quotidien triture
manipule et vous fait dire le contraire
de ce que vous vouliez préciser à
l'antenne ces gens sont effrayants de
malhonnêteté donc monsieur Barthez est
un malhonnête serait pas nouveau
quelle honte merci merci beaucoup
j'adore
et tous les chroniqueurs c'est vrai que
là voilà c'est question pour se dire
mais c'est un scandale en fait c'est
malhonnête enfin c'est malhonnête
intellectuellement c'est fallacieux
c'est un sidieux vous j'imagine que ça
enfin on voit que vous êtes très très
touché et c'est normal parce que il va
de votre responsabilité aussi de
médecins donc je trouve que c'est juste
ignoble mais je pense qu'effectivement
vous êtes sûr de victimes
aujourd'hui et je pense que clairement
il y a des journalistes aujourd'hui qui
sont à la rédaction quotidienne qui vont
regarder toute la journée c'est news et
qui vont se dire bah là si on peut
monter un petit truc un peu fait à la
cieux pour que ce soit un putaclic que
ce soit un bad buzz et à mon avis il y
en aura d'autres vous allez voir ça va
être le premier baiser responsable en
plus
on sait que le monta les montages on
peut leur faire dire ce qu'on veut mais
à la rigueur si c'était que vous la
victime on se dit ok après un buzz pas
un autre moi je pense effectivement à
ces jeunes qui vont qui vont se dire ok
si j'en prends une fois à une soirée de
temps en temps c'est pas très grave donc
du coup ils sont vraiment ils ont une
responsabilité de 100 par exemple c'est
ça qui est grave et c'est ce que disait
Brigitte parce que c'est vrai que quand
tu vois ça tu vois ce titre je vais dire
bah tu as vu même le médecin qui est en
train de sérieux Brigitte voilà
l'exemple depuis des années on a
confiance en elle on se dit bah même le
médecin dit tu as vu la petite dose ça
peut faire du bien donc c'est vrai que
depuis le côté connivence il est sur son
sur son pupitre canal à l'époque genre
sous-entendu plein de poudres à l'époque
un truc de Bobo là à l'époque genre
c'était l'esprit canal voilà il y a bien
sûr mais bon
je vais en prison demain mais non mais
non non parce que je pense après taper
tout ça donc j'ai fait une association
j'ai dit parce qu'en fait je me dis
demain je vais voir des détenus en
prison à Villepinte voilà je voulais
dire avec mon ami Momo à mineur voilà je
voulais dire je suis très heureux
d'aller voir demain voilà je serai
là-bas à Villepinte à partir à 15h on
mange une omelette et on arrive euh
non parce qu'en fait c'est pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai pensé je dis ils vont
parler de moi taper prison tu vois pas
ça c'est l'association
moi je suis choqué qu'une émission qui
s'est en sérieuse et crédible
journalistement comme quotidien s'amuse
à faire des montages de mauvaise foi
mais là c'est même pas qu'ils exagèrent
la réalité c'est qu'ils lui font dire
n'importe quoi Brigitte Neo il parle
même pas de la cocaïne tout ça pour
amuser la galerie là pour faire rire
trois bobos en plateau qui mangeaient
plus de soja ils font ce montage
malhonnête qui peut avoir des
conséquences dramatiques énervées tu
vois mais c'est vrai il décrédibilise
une rédaction il décrédibilise un
médecin vous êtes quand même médecin
dans la vie et jeter l'arrêt du tabac et
exactement imaginez Cyril si nous on
faisait des montages comme ça mais on se
ferait défoncer va pas se démontage
marrant sur l'amour et dans le pré c'est
pareil exactement là c'est une chaîne
une émission qui se veut sérieuse et
crédible journalistiquement c'est
extrêmement grave de faire ça et nous on
se serait fait défoncer donc c'est
injuste ma paye la guerre Canal+ TF1
c'est clair et net elle paye la guerre
entre les trucs de streaming là et après
nous parfois quand on tape sur sur les
chaînes TF1 les chaînes du groupe TF1
ils sont servis de cette dame pour se
pour se venger moi pour moi je vais vous
dire ils sont soulagés et c'est pas bien
c'est pas c'est malhonnête pour
s'excuser pas du tout non j'ai appelé
moi hier
il m'a dit qu'il était à l'étranger
qu'on me contacterait et personne ne l'a
contacté après le lui il va se dire il
est pas il est pas sur tous les sujets
non mais c'est honteux je ne comprends
pas j'aimerais qu'on m'explique je ne
comprends pas l'intérêt d'aller inciter
des jeunes à prendre de la cocaïne elle
a fait remontage
Brigitte franchement là je pense pas
qu'ils aient pensé à ça du tout ils sont
il y a un truc marrant on va le faire en
plus c'est sur cnews ça va nous
permettre de taper sur ces news c'est
tout ce qu'ils sont c’était pas pour
inciter les jeunes afin de la copine la
personne qui a fait le montage elle a
très bien visionner toute l'acronique et
pendant toute la chronique j'explique je
vous engage à la voir d'ailleurs la
chronique dans son entièreté j'explique
tous les méfaits de la cocaïne et et
donc la personne qui l'a vu c'est très
bien et qu'elle quand elle dit à petite
dose c'est bien c'est plutôt sympa ce
truc et tout que ça banalise finalement
la prise de cocaïne alors je passe mon
temps à dire qu'il ne faut arrêter de
banaliser la cocaïne le titre est clair
les dangers la cocaïne voilà le bordel
c'est normal ils ont voulu faire marrer
donc ils ont pris le truc voilà c'est
pervers moi je trouve ça pervers non
seulement pervers c'est à dire
qu'effectivement vous parlez de la mort
vous dites qu'on peut être dépendant
après une prise que ça détruit le
cerveau et eux ils retiennent juste
cette phrase il a des tourne c'est
extrêmement limite je vous le dis même
sur le plan juridique c'est une trahison
de la pensée c'est de la malhonnêteté ça
va très loin
je pense vous pourriez pour l'instant je
suis très énervé donc je vais me calmer
d'accord
vous pourriez il y a un préjudice grave
moral
par ce détournement c'est ça qui est
terrible moi dans mon métier moi j'ai
des gens à stopper le tabac et là ils
vont venir me voir bon le tabac non on
arrête mais la cocaïne on peut continuer
enfin
le tabac c'est tabou n'en viendra tous
ça reste important Brigitte en tout cas
on vous aime ici aussi je vous le dis
continue ce que vous faites vous êtes
formidable et c'est pas ça qui va
entacher votre carrière croyez-moi voilà
donc rassurez-vous et arrêtez de vous
énerver sortez allez kiffer et c'est
pour moi c'est cadeau
[Applaudissements]